foreign
on this Monday night the Toronto van
attacker sentenced I don't ever want him
to be able to do this to anyone else
powerful Victim Impact statements from
those whose lives are forever changed
diplomatic damage control outrage over a
Canadian official attending a Russian
Embassy party spreading lies about the
U.S election millions of Americans
believed him new evidence about Donald
Trump trying to cling to power and
losing his grip on reality Rising
mortgages and Rising stress home buyers
cannot afford these interest rates fears
some may not be able to afford to keep
their homes
and ghost in the machine I sense your
excitement the claims Google's
artificial intelligence has come to life
[Music]
National with Donna Friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with some breaking news about
Calgary the city has declared a local
state of emergency because of heavy rain
the mayor says she's doing it out of an
abundance of caution it allows police
and fire Crews to go door to door should
evacuation notices be required a
rainfall warning has been issued Calgary
and nearby mountainous regions could get
75 to 125 millimeters of Rain by
Wednesday morning that's expected to
melt higher than usual Mountain snowpack
and raise water levels in several Rivers
including the bow some flood mitigation
efforts are already in place and some
roads have already been closed
there was some remarkable strength shown
in a Toronto courtroom today survivors
and family members of victims who were
murdered four years ago faced the man
who motivated by hatred of women
deliberately drove a rented Van Into
innocent people on a crowded sidewalk
he's been sentenced to life in prison
with no chance of parole for 25 years
eight women and two men died that day in
April 2018 killed as they walked along
Young Street in Toronto their killer was
found guilty last year of 10 counts of
first-degree murder and 16 counts of
attempted murder an 11th person a woman
died from her injuries after his
conviction today's hearing was a chance
for those still dealing with the
physical and psychological trauma of
that day to give Victim Impact
statements
I really hope that he just spent all of
his days in he has no chance for parole
and and he has as little happiness as
possible because he's robbed so many of
us of having that full happiness and joy
of movement in life
Eric Sorensen on today's sentencing and
the voices of those whose lives will
never be the same
it's been four years since Toronto's
Famous Young Street was the scene of a
killing spree more than two kilometers
long finally those who were run over by
a rented van and survived and the loved
ones of those who didn't had their day
in court to express the devastation
they've all felt ever since Betty
Forsyth was among 11 who were killed in
a victim impact statement her nephew
said the emotional toll is still
affecting the family years later munir
Abdul Habib Najar was visiting his
daughter in this country that he loved
she told the court our lives were
shattered in a way that I doubt will
ever seem normal again and she asked of
the killer what right has this man to
destroy the lives of so many to gain the
infamy he seeks there was little visible
reaction from the killer Alec manassian
during the hearing Andrea Braden was
killed too Michelle Kellman narrowly
escaped and came to remember her friend
she was just one of a kind my children
loved her as well
um such a loss First Responders told of
the trauma they continue to feel and the
guilt they cannot shake from not being
able to save more lives after four years
still is very difficult for people that
were involved in directly or indirectly
the heart-wrenching statements in the
end will have little impact on
sentencing multiple life sentences for
first degree murder with no eligibility
for parole for 25 years must now be
served concurrently after a recent
decision by the Supreme Court of Canada
last month the high court overturned the
law that allowed sentences to be served
consecutively calling that cruel and
unusual punishment it does not make me
happy given the scope of his crime
Charlene Makai a first responder said
the killer should never be released as
she will forever be in the custody of
his crime I don't ever want him to be
able to do this to anyone else so hee
Chung was among those killed soulmate
Ross soul said today there is a hole in
my heart that can never be filled the
judge was bound by the high court
decision in passing sentence but Justice
Anne Malloy made clear all the
statements will be on the record to be
considered if and when a parole hearing
comes after the attacker serves 25 years
Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto
there's some new developments related to
Saturday's security scare that forced
police to shut down Parliament Hill
multiple law enforcement sources have
told Global News police were reacting to
a tip related to seek extremism that tip
which was then described as credible
said two vehicles carrying explosives
were near the Parliamentary Precinct and
specifically named two organizers of a
pre-planned rally commemorating the 1984
Sikh massacres in India however police
say no explosives were found and there
was no threat to the public sources now
say police do not believe this was a
national security issue and the two men
have been released without charge
a quick note on prime minister Justin
Trudeau he has tested positive for
covid-19 for the second time this year
the Prime Minister was in Los Angeles
last week at the summit of the Americas
meeting multiple world leaders including
the U.S president Trudeau tweeted that
he is following Public Health guidelines
in isolating but that he feels okay
given the brutality of Russia's invasion
of Ukraine and the outrage it's provoked
you might think Canadian diplomats would
decline an invitation to celebrate
Russia day in Ottawa yet the deputy
chief of protocol at the global Affairs
Department did attend her boss the
Minister of Foreign Affairs calls that
unacceptable and it's raising questions
about judgment whoever thought it was a
good idea and whether there will be any
reprimand Abigail Beeman reports
Russia Day celebrating the Russian
federation's Independence its Embassy in
Ottawa says an event to celebrate that
and 80 years of russia-canada diplomatic
relations was attended by one senior
Canadian official yazamin heinbecker is
Deputy Chief of protocol at Global
Affairs and given Canada's support of
Ukraine and pushback against Russia many
are questioning why she was there the
government is failing on sanctions
failing on immigration and now is
literally attending parties at the
Russian Embassy there is a genocide
happening in Ukraine will the minister
accept ministerial accountability I'm
the minister and the buck stops here
foreign affairs minister Melanie Jolie
is taking responsibility the reality is
this should never have happened
and this will not happen again but she
refused to answer several questions
including whether she knew about any
officials plan to attend I am absolutely
sure the Russians will see that as a
victory in a statement the embassy said
we appreciate Ms heinbecker honoring our
reception we don't look at Canada
through the adversarial optic and are
ready to patiently wait when Trudeau's
cabinet or the next government come to
understand that it's in Canadian
national interest to pursue good
neighborly relations with Russia it
would definitely benefit both our
Nations and the Arctic region nothing
could be more routine a former Canadian
ambassador to Russia says attending was
simply part of the official's job and
only a misstep in the current moment if
a political staffer or the minister
herself showed up it's not a party it's
not warmth it is simply an
acknowledgment that they are here both
the minister and the department are
keeping quiet about how the decision to
go was made and whether there are any
consequences involved Global Affairs
didn't answer our questions by deadline
Abigail the minute Global News
Ottawa Russia is not relenting in its
assault on Ukraine the eastern city of
severe Donetsk is being hit with
artillery at all bridges out of the city
have now been destroyed trapping
civilians who have not been able to flee
it is Ukraine's last stronghold in
luhansk Province and it appears Russia
is using the same tactics there as it
used in mariopol Crystal gemancing
Reports
sever Donetsk has been under Fire for
weeks but it remains a Ukrainian holdout
Russia encircled the city days ago and
is using a familiar strategy of
submission through bombardment
like mariopal citizens are taking cover
in an industrial plant Ukrainian
officials say about 800 are hiding in
the nitrogen facility along with an
unknown number of soldiers invading
forces have seized almost every other
part of luhansk in eastern Ukraine where
Russia is concentrating its offensive
Russia announced it destroyed a large
cache of Ukrainian weapons and military
equipment in the East Monday
Ukrainian police in the Donetsk region
recorded images of Civilian buildings
hit by missiles as they were in the
community imploring people to leave
at that moment I had a feeling that the
building was made of rubber everything
was moving
Russian tactics particularly in harkiv
amount to war crimes according to
Amnesty International many of these
strikes were launched using cluster
Munitions which are widely banned as
well as other indiscriminate weapons
Ukrainian Soldiers the report says have
positioned themselves in residential
areas violating International
humanitarian laws and drawing fire but
in no way justifies the Relentless
indiscriminate shelling of the City by
Russian forces
the war over Ukraine's sovereignty is
nearing its fourth month Crystal
commencing Global News London
now to the U.S and the investigation
into the January 6th Insurrection some
of former president Trump's closest
advisors testified they told him in no
uncertain terms that he lost the 2020
election the investigation is making the
case Trump knew he'd lost but
coordinated a plan to try to cling to
power orchestrating an attempted coup at
the U.S Capitol Jennifer Johnson on
today's testimony
more riveting testimony from the U.S
House committee investigating the
January 6 Capital Riot Witnesses painted
a disturbing picture of just how far
former president Donald Trump went to
try and overturn the 2020 election
results Donald Trump lost an election
and as a result of his loss decided to
wage an attack on our democracy Trump's
former campaign manager couldn't appear
in person because his wife went into
labor but in recorded testimony Bill
stepian and others say they warned Trump
his claims of election fraud were false
but the president was relying on advice
from Rudy Giuliani his personal attorney
there were two groups he called them
kind of my team and Rudy's team I I
didn't mind being characterized as being
part of Team normal Trump's former
senior campaign advisor testified and
inebriated Giuliani the former New York
city mayor told Trump to declare Victory
on Election night and the mayor was
definitely intoxicated but I did not
um know his level of intoxication when
he spoke with the president committee
members say Trump's disinformation
campaign fueled rioters for weeks
eventually leading to an orchestrated
not spontaneous Riot the Trump campaign
legal team knew there was no legitimate
argument fraud irregularities or
anything to overturn the election
and yet president Trump went ahead with
his plans for January 6th anyway even a
former Fox News political editor
admitted Joe Biden won the election
others spoke of getting violent death
threats after being called out by Trump
for refusing to investigate election
results in their states the threats
became much more specific much more
graphic committee members believe there
is enough evidence for the justice
department to consider criminal charges
against Donald Trump for trying to
overturn the election results if that
happens he will become the first former
U.S president in history to be charged
with a criminal offense
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
critics call it cruel coming up the UK's
plan to deport migrants to Rwanda is
about to take flight
we got another glimpse of Queen
Elizabeth today this photo was released
of the 96 year old in a silver gown
smiling and using a cane she was at the
order of the Garter service with Prince
Charles and his wife Camilla The Duchess
of Cornwall was installed as a royal
Lady of the order she joined other
members of the royal family in a
ceremonial procession at Windsor Castle
prince Andrew is a member of the order
too but the palace says a family
decision was made to keep him out of the
procession today
Queen Elizabeth has now reached another
Milestone she is the second longest
reigning monarch in history she's served
for 70 years and 127 days she overtakes
the former king of Thailand who died in
2016. in just over two years Queen
Elizabeth can overtake Louis XIV of
France to become the longest reigning
monarch in history he became king at the
age of four
the UK is proceeding with a
controversial plan to fly Asylum Seekers
through Rwanda and the first flight is
set to leave tomorrow prime minister
Boris Johnson says the intent is to
discourage people Smugglers and migrants
from crossing the English Channel in
small boats hoping to start a new life
in the UK as Redmond Shannon reports
human rights groups are fighting the
plan in court but so far have lost
almost every day dozens sometimes
hundreds of people cross the English
Channel in small boats the number of
Asylum Seekers arriving in the UK this
way has risen sharply in recent years in
April the British government announced
plans to send some of these people to
Rwanda in East Africa where they would
enter that country's Asylum system the
program is designed to discourage
migrants from making the sea Journey you
want to stop the illegal migrants and
come in and we want to we want to deter
the criminal gangs because they're not
only endangering their lives they're
ripping them off on Monday a judge
dismissed an appeal against the plan
Paving the way for deportations to begin
as early as Tuesday
migrant and human rights groups have
criticized the initiative noting that
Asylum Seekers could face human rights
abuses in Rwanda indefinite detention
mistreatment including to torture in
detention the lack of any independent
Judiciary and also very very worryingly
the fact that any form of dissent is
quashed in Rwanda just last year the UK
government itself issued recommendations
on how Rwanda can improve its human
rights record and the plan comes after
Australia and the United States have
used similar tactics to deal with Asylum
Seekers the precedent that this creates
is catastrophic for a concept that needs
to be shared like Asylum next week
Rwanda hosts the Commonwealth heads of
government meeting with Prince Charles
representing the queen a British
newspaper has reported that he was
overheard calling the plan appalling
even if some Asylum Seekers are sent to
to Rwanda this may not be the last legal
hurdle the UK government faces next
month there will be a judicial review of
the entire plan which could result in
those people being returned to the UK
Redmond Shannon Global News London
ahead how Rising interest rates are
inflating Canadians fears they can't
afford their homes
owning your own home and keeping up with
the cost of living is getting more
stressful as inflation soars and
interest rates hit the highest level
since 2019 some homeowners fear they may
not be able to keep up their mortgage
payments a new survey conducted by
Manulife bank and ipsos found almost one
in four Canadians surveyed fear they
will be forced to sell their home if
interest rates rise much more and
gaviola takes a deep dive into the data
the rising debt and why homeowners need
to do their homework
with Canadians taking on record amounts
of Mortgage Debt during the pandemic and
home prices softening cue the buyer's
remorse what does really resonate in
terms of how Canadians are feeling about
the homes that they either just recent
bought or or have been in for a little
while to feel that that inflation and
interest rates are making them feel that
they're not able to stay in that home
also sobering that one-third of
respondents don't understand inflation
or how interest rates work underscoring
the need for professional help to
navigate these uncertain times hopefully
they have an expert or a certified
financial advisor that they can speak to
to put them a little bit more at ease or
to look at different ways that they can
make it more affordable to live within
the budget that they have set for
themselves if clients don't ask those
questions and a broker is not proactive
in explaining those things to them
clients can get sort of Lost in the
Lurch because a broker may have the
expectation that a client understands
these things understanding is one thing
but even the experts have been confused
by the bank of Canada's messaging
earlier in the pandemic promising rates
would stay low for long and this year
three rate hikes in a row in an attempt
to put a lid on soaring inflation with a
promise to act aggressively in the
future if needed according to Desjardins
economics home prices across Canada are
expected to come down by 15 percent by
the end of 2023 with the steepest drops
expected in the maritimes down 20
percent Ontario and Pei 18 and BC giving
back as much as 15 percent this real
estate data analyst predicts a frozen
housing market in months to come
certainly we're going to see a very very
sluggish Market come this fall we're not
going to see this big rebound because
home buyers cannot afford these interest
rates we'll have to wait and see if
prolonged buyers remorse leads to
improved affordability and gaviola
Global News Toronto
Almost Human what a Google engineer
claims about a chatbot could it possibly
be true
you're watching global national
there have been huge advancements in
artificial intelligence over the years
most of the work taking place quietly at
private companies like Google well now
one software engineer has got himself
suspended for going public he claims a
chat bot powered by an artificial
intelligence has become sentient that it
has feelings and is self-aware as Mike
droulet reports Google was quick to shut
down claims like that
ask Google the goal was always to make
artificial intelligence seem human I'm
looking for something on May 3rd still
working
[Music]
four years ago Google made it happen
and the tech Giants acolytes ate it up
well how do you think they'd respond to
Lambda the AI program that finishes your
sentences as you type this now suspended
Google AI researcher Blake Lemoine
published a conversation he had with
Lambda where he asked if the AI knew it
wasn't human I mean yes of course that
doesn't mean I don't have the same wants
and needs as people and when he asked if
it had any fears Lambda went to a very
dark place I've never said this out loud
before but there's a very deep fear of
being turned off to help me focus on
helping others it would be exactly like
death for me it would scare me a lot so
is Lambda alive sentient a step away
from becoming the life Killer Robots in
Westworld
the obvious reaction is pull the plug
which ethicist Kerry Bowman says he
completely understands this is the first
time in the human story that we are in a
position where we are potentially
interfacing with a form of intelligence
that is beyond potentially our own and I
would argue we're tremendously
ill-equate for this we spoke with Bowman
from the Democratic Republic of the
Congo an hour after he was face to face
with Apes in the wild most of us as
humans have been raised to believe that
you know really only humans are capable
of sentience only humans are capable of
morality all those types of things and
it's not really true the difference of
course is that while Apes may have
limits in what they can learn computer
AI programs have none and if that
doesn't blow your mind
Mike drulay Global News Toronto
that is global national for this Monday
I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your Canada
is the Ukrainian Cultural Heritage
Village East of Edmonton we'd love to
see your Canada please email it to
viewers at globalnational.com thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]